all right before we get to my interview
with the professor Jordan Pederson which
I know a lot of people are waiting for
coffee time has come the time has come
to decide what will the labels look like
on our upcoming david pakman show coffee
to remind you we are going to have to
coffee blends both roasted by blue fire
coffee roasters their local about 45
minutes from our studio I was over there
over the weekend Pat and I actually
watched coffee beans get roasted with
Pat Maloney who owns the company we
started with green coffee it goes into
the roaster and in about 11 or 12
minutes we had a medium medium dark
roast ready to go and I saw it all
happen it goes from what looks like
something that might have fallen off of
a tree to the coffee that you would
grind and roast at home I'm hugely
excited about this yeah that must been
quite the experience and forgive me for
my ignorance but does the coffee start
out green and then the beans become
Brown is that how it that's exactly
right yet the the beans start out green
and very small and as you roast them
they expand they release moisture so the
moisture content goes down and they turn
brown the the color of coffee that that
were sort of used to seeing so we're
gonna have to roasts we will have a
roast for espresso machines that is
going to be called progressive wake-up
call the audience came up with these
names we will have a drip coffee roasts
and that will be called freedom of the
press now how to set up the voting for
the labels which I'm about to show you
it was complex number one some people
listen to the show so they're not going
to be able to see what the labels look
like for those people please go to the
youtube channel and check out the clip
that we did for this segment uh we could
do a poll on david pakman.com but
there's no easy way to link to pictures
of the labels in the poll so here's the
way we're going to do it i'm going to
show you the different labels all you
have to do is email me you can but write
an email to david at david pakman.com
say hey here's the one i want for
progressive wake-up call here's the one
i want for freedom of the press the
other option is you go to david
pakman.com and use the contact form okay
we will be tallying votes manually it
seems so old school but because of all
the different platforms were on i
couldn't think of another way to do this
so here we go let's start first with
a progressive wake up call up first
submission is from Bo Barnett who
submitted the progressive wake-up call
label in three different colors uh I'll
probably end up picking the color but if
you like this this is the bow Barnett
progressive wake-up call label next we
have the Cheryl Alvarez progressive
wake-up call label this is taking on
more of a smart phone home screen motif
which is pretty cool and then we have
Madeleine quirks submission for
progressive wake-up call this I believe
Pat we have in two different colors
which we can show people again I'll
probably end up picking the color but if
you like this one this is the Madeleine
quirk progressive wake-up call label and
then lastly we have florian submissions
for progressive wake-up call he has for
submissions this right here is florian
one progressive wake-up call next we
have florian to progressive wake-up call
then we have florian three progressive
wake-up call and lastly we have florian
for progressive wake-up call all right
now freedom of the press this is the
other roast for freedom of the press
this is the first submission this is
Cheryl submission for freedom of the
press uh two different sizes i think
it's probably going to be the three by
four label you see on the left freedom
of the press here is madeline quirks
submission for freedom of the press I
believe we have this one also in two
different colors and will show that to
you and then we have Florian's three
submissions for freedom of press this is
Florian one freedom of the press very
cool very coffee like then we have the
second Florian submission for freedom of
the press going with a very different
color scheme and lastly we have Florian
three fredom freedom of the press a uh
very uh I don't know what I would call
it sort of more minimalist system so
please email me to vote I i know this is
complex this is the best way we could
think of to do it send me your emails
what do you want for freedom of the
press what label do you like for
progressive wake-up call we will
announce the winners will give it a few
days maybe
he can we will announce the winners next
week and then the coffee will be on sale
before you know it